SIDDHARTHA AGARWAL: Hi,
I'm Siddhartha Agarwal,
and I'm responsible for
our Saas partnerships
here at Google and
the co-innovation
that we do with our ISVs.
I wanted to welcome you to
the session today, which
is going to talk about
how ISVs are accelerating
the digital transformation that
their customers are asking them
for and how these ISVs and Saas
companies are co-innovating
with Google to deliver
that transformation.
And we also have a very
exciting customer story
to share with you on
how the ISV has actually
driven that co-innovation,
leveraging both Google
capabilities and GCP
capabilities or Google Cloud
Platform capabilities.
So ISVs are being
asked to accelerate
the digital transformation
by their customers,
and in order to
deliver this, the ISVs
are on a number
of cloud journeys.
And I'd love to share with you
these cloud journeys and then
talk about some
customer examples
and also how Google is using
co-innovation to help the ISVs
on these cloud journeys.
So starting off with the
multi-cloud expansion
side of it, most ISV
and Saas partners
are being asked
to leverage cloud
to deliver higher
availability, which
might mean delivering
an active-active DR site
or bursting into the
cloud or to modernize
their on-premise
applications, which
might involve lifting
and shifting existing
on-prem assets, or
actually moving out
of complete data centers,
or to expand into regions
with significant compliance and
data residency requirements,
and most importantly, to
keep increasing the security,
their infrastructure security,
their user security, their data
security.
Security is paramount.
And so to help our ISVs
along these journeys,
we have built a number of
capabilities in our platform,
for example, Anthos.
[INAUDIBLE],, which is
a financial services
ISV, leveraged Anthos, which
is a financial services
application delivered on premise
to be able to actually burst
when additional
capacity is needed
into the cloud with an
active-active architecture
or be able to create
a DR scenario where,
in case something
went wrong on premise,
the application would be
live at any given point
in time from the public cloud.
Also, Google's focused
a lot on plan and scale
by delivering the world's
largest network, which
was built for applications
like search, and YouTube,
and Gmail to enable ISVs to
reach their customers where
they are, and from a security
perspective, providing
innovations like
confidential compute using
AMD's in-memory encryption
and our tightened security
chips on our hardware to
deliver significant security.
And openness is a
key tenet for Google,
where we have a longstanding
history of championing
open source and extending
that to Google Cloud by making
open source a
first-class citizen.
This could be for third-party
open source, such as Kafka
[INAUDIBLE] but as
you very well know,
also Kubernetes an
Istio, which has
led the transformation of
modernizing application
development.
Every organization is focused
on innovating to differentiate,
and ISVs have to
innovate to compete
more effectively to grow
top line by expanding
into new markets.
In order to do
this, they're asking
how intelligence can be
leveraged to make business
processes more automated
and predictable
without needing a lot
of data scientist skills
and how their users
can be engaged
via voice and messaging.
So for example, in
intelligence, how
can they deliver better
business outcomes?
How can they get
insight from documents?
How can they do multilingual
translations in real time?
And user experience
is now no longer
about just browser-based
experiences,
so using virtual agents,
intelligence chat bots,
and even search as the new
paradigm for interaction.
And it's become
really important to be
able to use industry-specific
solutions, deliver
industry-specific solutions
to your customers,
which means delivering
intelligence for retail
or delivering solutions that are
specific to financial services
or the public sector.
Given the scale at which
date is being generated,
insight from this
data can no longer
be derived with on-prem
traditional infrastructure,
be it around compute
or around storage,
so customers are asking ISVs
how they can get insights from
and act upon data at
exabytes and petabytes scale.
And this involves being
able to leverage streaming
data and batch data to be able
to make intelligent decisions
on the streaming data that is
coming in as the data is coming
in to be able to
blend first-party data
and third-party data,
first-party data that might be
the ISV's application and
third-party data that might be
coming from outside,
and enable business
users at these customers
to be able to make
those decisions
such that they don't
have to be data scientists,
they don't have to know AIML.
They can just be getting
value from that data.
And then we're going to talk
about this in the customer
story or the ISVs story.
It's really about
personalization
and segmentation.
How can you be able to
personalize the engagement
with the customers
using broader data that
could come from Google?
It could come from
Google Ads, it
could come from Google
Search, et cetera.
Or being able to segment
the audience and being
able to target the audience
in the way you want--
So to that end, what
we've done is, one,
we're providing a very rich set
of AIML capabilities and very
strong AIML capabilities
to be able to, for example,
get insight from vision,
from speech, et cetera.
But we've also built
solutions on top of the AI.
So for example, we've built
a contact center AI solution
where in real time, as
customers are talking,
we're understanding the
intent of those customers
and having a virtual
agent be able to engage
with that customer
across multiple turns
without needing an agent
involved at all, being
able to do that in real time,
where the data is running
on our TPUs, the analysis
is running on our TPUs,
being able to get insight
from the conversations that
are being had.
And if the answer cannot be
solved by the virtual agent
themselves, being able to
transfer that over to a live
agent and being able to provide
that agent with intelligent
insight on how to respond and
what is the next best action
that they should be suggesting.
Similarly from documents,
being able to get insight
from documents, for example,
from a mortgage document.
How do you understand what is
the rate, what is the financing
terms, et cetera?
Or from license, being
able to understand,
is this a valid
driver's license?
Which state does this
driver's license belong to?
Or from contracts,
being able to get
the sense of what terms
have been agreed to,
limitation of
liability, et cetera.
And then from an
analytics lens, being
able to provide you
the ability to stream
in data at large
scale into BigQuery,
where we've separated out
compute and storage, such
that you can analyze
this data at scale,
blend the data at scale
with petabytes of data being
crunched on at the same time.
And then you can actually
build monetization models
on top of this data,
where customers
who have really large amounts
of data that is really
valuable data that
they want to be
able to share out and monetize,
they can actually do very
granular access to that data.
They can do governance and
access control to the data,
and they can monetize the
data from BigQuery itself,
so lots of really
cool capabilities that
are being delivered
for both of those
journeys to differentiate
with innovation
and to be able to get
insights from real-time data.
And what's really exciting
is how ISVs have not only
been doing co-innovation
with Google Cloud
Platform, but the broader
Google properties.
That includes Google Pay, Google
Shopping, Android, Chrome, et
cetera.
For example, in retail,
ISVs are looking
at how they can
leverage Google shopping
to be able to optimize the
price that is being offered up
by merchants that are
selling on their platform
or to be able to improve the
merchant discoverability that
exists for merchants on their
platform onto Google Shopping.
And we'll be talking
about how Google Ads are
being used by that ISV.
And also, these ISVs are
working on delivering
very smart industry and
horizontal solutions
by embedding intelligence to
deliver business processes that
are much better in understanding
what should be happening,
what is the customer looking for
in various specific industries.
Now, one of the key areas is
around developer engagement.
Developers, as we know,
are the new kingmakers,
and everyone is focused on
how to get these developers
attached to the platform.
And so ISVs are looking at
how we can help the developers
upscale with new technologies
such as containerization,
microservices, AIML, and
really on DevOps and SRE
because we're delivering
applications at scale,
like Gmail, and how can they
improve their DevOps and SRE
capabilities to deliver that
same capability at large scale.
What's really interesting is we
found the developers are trying
to provide insight
into product analytics
to the product manager,
so which features
are being used, what
functionality is being used,
and what are some informed
intelligent recommendations,
and how to enhance the
usage of the product.
And then no Saas application or
no application out of the box
delivers all the
value that is needed,
so ISVs are also looking at
building a rich extension
platform, for example,
leveraging our Apigee
capabilities to
provide API exposure
and to be able to monetize
and manage those APIs
or to provide business
logic extensions that
can ride alongside the
ISV or SaaS application.
And then we're very focused on
partnering for joint success
with the ISVs.
The ISVs have
asked us what we're
doing to invest in developing
and innovating with you,
how we can increase the joint
go-to-market with the ISVs,
and how we can accelerate
distribution with the ISVs.
So we're making
co-investment decisions
to provide unique
product engineering
of co-innovation funds,
defining joint go-to-market
with joint verticalization,
market expansion
planning, or global, regional
field alignment and accelerated
distribution, being able to
leverage the Google field,
being able to leverage the
Google Cloud Marketplace.
And finally, executive
alignment and a focus
on customer success--
how do we make sure
that our customers
are going live, are onboarding,
and being really successful?
So these are the ways that
we're working with the ISVs
to enable their
journey to the cloud
to deliver multi-cloud
capabilities, to deliver
intelligence embedded
within their own solutions,
including for
industry-specific use cases,
and driving co-innovation
that's not just
about Google Cloud but also the
broader Google product areas.
With that, I'm really excited
to invite to this discussion
Guy Hellier from OpenText,
whose team has done
an amazing job at driving
co-innovation to deliver value
to their customers.
Welcome, Guy.
GUY HELLIER: Hello, Siddhartha.
Thank you very much.
SIDDHARTHA AGARWAL: Great to
have you on this discussion
here.
So can you just do
a little background
on yourself and OpenText?
GUY HELLIER: Sure.
I'm responsible for product
management in our Digital
Experience product unit.
OpenText is a very large
information management
solutions company, and so we
focus on digital experience,
content services, business
network, information security,
and how that all helps our
customers to transform.
And in the area of
digital experience,
that's really about
helping our brand customers
be able to drive
conversions for customers
through digital
experience to grow revenue
and to do that on all
the different channels
that a customer journey and
touch points that a customer
journey occurs on.
SIDDHARTHA AGARWAL:
That's wonderful, Guy.
So it sounds like
marketers are going
to be very happy
with your solution
because it drives higher
conversion and top
line for them.
So can you share an example of
how this might be experienced
both by an end customer
of your customer
and by the marketing
organization in your customer?
GUY HELLIER: Sure.
So let's take
purchasing a house.
And as a target customer of
mine is purchasing a house,
then they're looking for a
new house insurance provider.
They might come from a different
set of backgrounds, maybe
different interests,
geographies,
and so as they're searching on
my site for product information
anonymously, the Google
Marketing Platform
is able to help understand
and model their behavior.
And then what we're trying
to do is, on that site,
help our brand customers
be able to provide the most
relevant experience
for those customers,
knowing their interests
and just being
able to target and to
personalize in the most
effective way, whether
that's on the site,
a mobile app, in
the contact center,
as you've already discussed, in
any type of touch point, chat,
any of those.
SIDDHARTHA AGARWAL:
And that's exciting.
So they get dynamic landing
pages delivered to them,
and they experience
the same, even
if they start the
transaction on one channel
and continue their transaction
across the other channels.
So you know this
question is coming, Guy,
but what made you think
of Google or partnering
with Google?
What is unique about Google
that helped you deliver
the solution to your customers?
GUY HELLIER: Well, as
we've talked about,
I think the thing
that our customers are
interested in is how to make
sure that the customer's
journey is as relevant
as possible to make sure
that that customer understands
the products really
well and finds the right
products and services
and how to use them
in the long run.
That means being able to
help both anonymous users
and customers, as
well as the known
and the logged-in customer.
And to do this,
you need content,
you need a lot of
content, and you
need the data, the
information, the context,
and the understanding of that
information of that context
to make the experience
really relevant.
So our experience platform helps
to deliver brand experiences,
customer portals, commerce
experiences, communications,
all of these, while the
marketing platform is
delivering that same brand
experience through advertising
into so many different touch
points that are off the site,
delivered by Google
Marketing Platform.
So the first place
that we've innovated
has been around
understanding content,
and as you've
already talked about,
content comes in many different
forms, of course, imagery.
It can be audio, voice.
It could be all
kinds of audio that
goes with video, of
course, understanding
video and the nature
of video, intelligence
for that, and being able
to translate content.
So we worked with all
of those solutions
with our experience
platform and the ability
to run it on the
Google Cloud Platform.
But we're also innovating
around the use of data
together with both BigQuery and
the Google Marketing Platform.
SIDDHARTHA AGARWAL:
That's amazing integration
that you've done or your team
has done working with Google,
so can we dive just
a little bit deeper
into vision AI or AutoML?
How did you use that to make
a marketer's job lot easier?
GUY HELLIER: Yeah, great
question, and this is really
where rubber meets the road.
So with all of this content
and all of these experiences,
marketers need tools that
allow them to understand it,
to automate it, to work
with it without having
to do a lot of manual effort.
So vision AI, all of the
media-centric AI tools--
they help us specifically
to be able to pull out.
Is there a bicycle in this image
or to be able to understand
that there is a bicycle.
It's outdoors.
Or maybe there's
branding, logos,
that are in a particular image.
Or maybe there's
actually a product
that's displayed or
being referenced here.
All of that
information was really
critical to be able to
automate what a marketer works
with in the first place and then
allow that tagging to be used,
even to deliver advertising in
a more accurate and relevant way
so that the marketing platform
can use that tagging to be very
relevant for end customers.
And so that-- whether it's
on images, or on video,
or on speech, all of that
cognitive understanding
of content is really important.
SIDDHARTHA AGARWAL:
That's great.
That gave me goosebumps as
you were talking about it
into the kind of insight
that you were able to get.
So I know you've worked with the
ISV/Saas Center of Excellence
that we launched
earlier this year.
Can you share a little bit
about how they helped you
on this journey?
GUY HELLIER: Yeah, a
great question, and this
is where I want to bring in
the BigQuery side of things
because customers have
so much third-party data.
They have transactions.
They have information
about their products.
about customers
from their CRM systems.
They have all kinds of very
specific first-party data
that, bringing those models
together with the advertising
audiences, it allows customers
to build a very rich learning
model to understand how
to augment the audiences
and to be able to target.
And so we've worked with
the Center of Excellence
to be able to understand how
the Google Cloud services can
enable that, how we integrate
that with our experience
platform, and how it rolls
out for the customer.
They've been instrumental
to understand
the modeling and
how that actually
gets used by our customers.
SIDDHARTHA AGARWAL:
Great, and I'm
really proud to hear that
the Saas Center of Excellence
has been helpful in defining
the architecture in working
hands-on with you to
put a PLC together
and to help you feel
comfortable around the platform.
So thank you so much, Guy.
This is wonderful.
And it's this kind
of innovation,
when an ISV like OpenText
leverages Google Marketing
Platform, which is
outside of Google Cloud,
uses AI from the
Google Cloud Platform,
leverages BigQuery
for large-scale data
and then deploys all of this
on Google Cloud Platform
to deliver a brand-new
product for themselves that
differentiates them and
delivers significant value
to their customer and to
their customer's customer.
So if there's one message I want
you to take away, it's this.
It's not about what
is, but what could be.
It's not about what exists, but
what we can create together.
Nothing is impossible,
and failure
should be welcomed to
learn from and help
create 10x opportunities.
That's Google culture.
That's Google co-innovation, to
feel comfortable with failure,
learn, and then create
10x opportunities.
Think not just about GCP
or Google Cloud Platform,
but the broader Google
capabilities of Google
Ads, Google Marketing Platform,
Search, Android, Chrome, et
cetera.
We are providing a canvas,
we're providing brushes
and a beautiful
palette of colors,
and we look forward
to seeing you
paint your vibrant
masterpieces onto this canvas.
Please come share
your ideas with us.
We are here to help.
Thank you.